et déjà quelques incidents cette après
midi entre m directeur justement et
instituteurs les second contestant les
premiers un dialogue en tout cas
difficile à la lumière de ces dernières
semaines d'autant que les parents
d'élèves ne comprennent pas bien
l'enjeu de cette querelle en voici
l'illustration dans une école du 13ème
arrondissement de paris d'où reviennent
lorraine cusin et andré sort une école
du xiiie arrondissement dans un quartier
plutôt populaire 200 enfants 140
familles ici la semaine dernière les
enseignants avant la grève ont provoqué
une réunion d'information à l'intention
des parents
quarante familles se sont déplacées mais
dans l'ensemble dans cette école si les
parents ne comprennent guère les
nouveaux textes ou s'y intéresse de loin
on n'est pas vraiment
bien bien nous pourrons n'étant pas
concerné vraiment directement ou pour
balancer sur que l'école marché bien
depuis des années de cette façon le
pourquoi du jour au lendemain
faut-il tout remettre en question et
créer une autre à notre statut aussi ça
m'intéresse j'ai pas suivi parce que je
travaille j'ai pas la communion réunion
saleh signé était déjà persuadé que le
directeur vaut à 20 euros sur eux vous
avez le fan est directeur qu'a posée
elle n'irait archi comble directeur
était le directeur
il y avait les mettre à côté tout
fonctionnait très bien et du journal le
maire son appart et demi je dois parler
de nouveaux traits du directeur dont les
gens se sont posé des questions pourquoi
il est déjà directeur pourquoi changer
le statut est ce que ça veut dire
la difficulté pour les instituteurs
hostile au texte sera donc maintenant
d'arriver à sensibiliser les familles
sur leurs actions à venir
c'est notre rôle d'expliquer et de
continuer expliqué comme on le fait avec
les enfants explique plusieurs fois pas
aux parents séparés mais vous êtes leur
seule source d'information j'espère
quand même qu'on qu'ils regardent la
télévision qui lisent les journaux enfin
le seul contact vraiment humain c'est
quand même l'école ne prévoit aucune
grève pour l'instant à partir de jeudi
matin durant la première heure tandis
qu'une moitié des instituteurs
accueillera les enfants l'autre
organisera des rencontres avec les
familles le mini